hi there steve here
i've done a bit of korean today but it's
my birthday first of all i want to thank
everyone people who here on
skype and on twitter and facebook
who have sent me birthday greetings and
i'm going to try to respond when i find
the time but
uh busy again as you know i'm getting in
all this cooking action we had a nice
big brunch and and now i'm making a lamb
shank
for dinner and i haven't done this
before and it's going to be with
vegetables and
wine and stuff like that and
in sort of a casserole where i'm going
to first sear it and get the vegetables
going and add the
the the wine and whatnot then i'm gonna
put it in the oven for an hour and a
half or so i don't know how it's gonna
turn out
um but
birthday i'm 71 years old
um you know i think back to 50 years ago
i was i was at
in ottawa my first year as a canadian
government trade commissioner
uh i was lucky enough to be selected
because i wrote the foreign service exam
in paris i wrote it in french and i
think that gave me an advantage in so
far as being selected as an anglophone
i only wrote the exam i only became
aware of it of its existence through a
friend of mine who was writing the exam
then circumstances were such that uh the
government had they were looking for
someone to learn chinese so i
volunteered for that i in fact started
studying chinese on my own just to show
that i was interested
and all through my career and business
is is the same way
you know i'm i'm totally aware of the
fact that the number one
factor that governs what happens to us
in life is luck
i think how we respond to these
opportunities uh that's up to us and
that's a matter of our attitude and
energy and all the other things however
fundamentally it's luck luck determines
where we are born
luck determines what capacities we are
born with luck determines whom we meet
uh which people direct us where which
decisions we make is often a matter of
luck
for that reason
i'm a big supporter
of society
redistributing the luck redistributing
the opportunity helping those who had
less luck because if i had more luck
uh there's no reason why i wouldn't give
back
to society or to others therefore i
don't mind paying my taxes i've never
tried to evade paying my taxes it annoys
me that government servants
any organization likes to grow
any organization sees the growth of the
organization as the ultimate goal like
government sees the growth of their
organization rather than looking after
the potential beneficiary as the bigger
goal i've seen this in language
instruction for immigrants where they
are more concerned
with these uh sort of immigrant service
organizations and they're all kind of
looking after each other rather than
you know activities that would simply
benefit the immigrant but might not
benefit the whole immigrant services
industry
however nothing is perfect everything
has imperfections but as a principle the
idea that
we redistribute the opportunity is a
very good thing and this means
unfortunately a higher
level of taxation than many of us would
like there are those who say well i
shouldn't have to pay tax on anything i
earned my money myself and it's all mine
that's not true because you benefit from
a lot of uh the infrastructure in
society schools roads you name it you
benefit from the luck that came your way
yes you responded to that but even the
fact that you were say energetic or
entrepreneurial in a sense is also a
matter of luck that you were born with
those qualities so
i think that we should all want to
contribute back to the society because
it makes it a better society to live in
and i think the ultimate morality is not
religion or some ideology of
whatever ism it amounts to basically
reciprocity
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you so you do things to help others
and others are going to do things to
help you that is it it doesn't matter
what you believe in i don't believe that
religious people are more moral than
atheists atheists can be at least as
moral
as religious people in fact i prefer to
think that if i do
things for other people i do this as a
sense of solidarity to my fellow human
beings and not because i am hoping that
somebody is looking over me up there and
is going to uh you know
treat me better because i did whatever
i'm not into that kind of stuff at all
so that's what i'm looking at as i'm 71
years old enjoying my language learning
enjoying getting into cooking which i
haven't really done at all and now it's
like anything else it's like language
learning it's like starting a new
language as you get into it it becomes
you know la petite home as they say in
french the appetite comes with the
appetite comes with the eating so the
more i do of it the more i'm interested
the more i enjoy now going to the
supermarket now i have a better sense of
which supermarkets are good and which
are not good where they have good
produce not good produce so it just
brings a whole new world which i'm
enjoying and now i gotta run off and
finish preparing dinner but thank you
again for all the uh well wishes for my
birthday and i have i have been doing
some korean it may be only you know a
little bit of listening while cooking
and
reading and linking but i'm not letting
go i'm committed bye for now